a third force in the Ukraine conflict
soldiers from Russia's Wagner group
essentially hired mercenaries many of
them hired from Russian prisons
the group is controlled by Evgeni
pragosin a close Ally of Vladimir Putin
and this week featured in a video made
by his own media service visiting
injured fighters in a Saint Petersburg
Clinic
you must not pity a soldier at War you
must take care of him therefore each
Soldier should be unique with more than
50 000 deployed in Ukraine the Wagner
group has been on the U.S radar for a
number of months and now it's been
declared a significant transnational
criminal organization in coordination
with this designation we will also
impose additional sanctions next week
against Wagner and its support network
across multiple continents these actions
recognize the Transcontinental threat
that Wagner poses including through its
ongoing pattern of serious criminal
activity
at the same time though the U.S
maintains that a mounting rivalry
between the Wagner group and the former
Russian military could impact on Russian
performance in the ongoing War we are
seeing indications including in
intelligence the tensions between Wagner
and the Russian Ministry of Defense are
increasing
Wagner is becoming a rival Power Center
to the Russian military and other
Russian Ministries the Russian army has
a very low morale so the only way to
spike morale and to bring uh victories
is to bring this people who get a lot of
money who are basically professional
mercenaries and also professional
criminals uh released from jails that's
what Stalin actually did uh as well the
US has also accused North Korea of
arming the Wagner group displaying
images of what it says are Russian rail
cars being loaded with North Korean
weapon systems
them
potentially putting the group in a
position where it could change
Battlefield Dynamics in Ukraine
something the U.S clearly hopes its
sanctions will help prevent
my Khanna Al Jazeera Washington